okay just my final question if i may
could you just confirm and i just
appreciate a yes or a no
that you met with the former kgb officer
alexandra lebanov lebadep
when you were foreign secretary without
officials on the 28th of april 2018.
well
i i i have to i i'd have to check but uh
you're having a lapse of memory again no
but that sounds but you know if you're
asking a very specific question about a
very specific date and i really i i
would have to i'd have to get back i
certainly have met the gentleman in
question who's uh who's uh
who who used to be the proprietor of the
london evening standard i would i was
uh when i was mayor of london so i i i
certainly am not going to deny having
met
uh alexander lebedev i certainly have as
far as i remember
he used to own uh the london evening but
with officials when you were foreign
secretary did you meet with officials or
without officials
i i certainly met him without officials
right and um you know as i say he's a
he's a perhaps you could write a
proprietor of uh
you could write to us for those of you
very happy very happy to a very happy
specific answer to that very specific
question
yes
prime minister i mean you said you met
him without officials was that
presumably was when you were mayor of
london when you were foreign secretary
did you meet alexander levadev i i think
i would absolutely do but but i probably
did
as i said i would i would need to check
you used to regularly meeting him i mean
is it probably because you meet him
often or probably because you can't
remember i i've met him on a very few
occasions
on the occasion you're mentioning if
that was when i was foreign secretary
then yes
without officials yes
did you report your officials that you
had met him
uh i think i i think i did mention yes
and where did you meet him
um you know
i i met him
uh initially as it happens but i i
really you know
i i forget anyway well perhaps you're
you're right personal engagement yeah
it was if that's exactly
we'll move on